hey 42 here 70% of the silent movies
made in America have been lost welcome
to RIF the average human body contains
zero point two milligrams of gold until
the 1940s fake snow in movies was made
by painting corn flakes white if you
drink one glass of water for every
alcoholic beverage it significantly
reduces your chance of getting a
hangover
Usain Bolt 81 thousand chickens uhlet's
during the Beijing Olympics because he
didn't like Chinese food sheep can see
behind themselves without moving their
heads there are more libraries in
Britain's prisons than there are in its
schools if you hold your breath and put
your face in cold water your heart will
immediately slow down by 25% a person
usually makes a lot of hand gestures
when they're telling the truth when
telling a lie however a person's hands
tend to stay still
one in five kidneys donated in the US
are thrown away because a suitable
recipient can't be found
people spend 47% of their waking hours
thinking about something other than what
they're doing
anthropologists believe that man has
known how to use fire for 500,000 years
but only learned how to make it himself
12,000 years ago a peppier is a waiter
whose sole job is to go around with a
pepper grinder a moment is actually a
medieval unit of time that means 90
seconds at Stalin's funeral 500 people
were trampled to death the force
required to pull one leg from quicksand
is the same needed to lift a small car
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you